don't be afraid to make mistakes
they will only stay with you for the
rest of your life
it is the book defines the world it
illuminated the light of the human
spirit in the same way that Jesus Gandhi
and Kenya are known to be masters of
taught it is impossible to think of
Felix Kjellberg PewDiePie as anything
else so many nice will change as people
discover this book PewDiePie has with
this book loves you reinvented
philosophy right he's helping everyone
political leaders academics economics
kids cats toffee rappers all to reach
their highest potential
my favorite quote it's like being asked
what my favorite child is I don't have a
child right but there are so many and
the entire concept I mean super ology is
that each phrase and each sentence are
all connected by the spine of the book
running from your problems won't make
you skinny
I would know it is this kind of poetic
beauty that demands to be tattooed on
your wrist an italic script right Oh
when my wife left me I hit the bottle
hard I was down and under I was going
anywhere but some well just but then I
discovered this we love you and was
introduced to the world of pdy discuss
it so the beautiful world of PewDiePie
and everything changed when I was young
I threw myself into academia I was
really killed for my looks for a young
age and I know that yes I'm not a
conventionally handsome man I'm no hairy
piles but thanks to the teaching of this
book loves you I am now able to look in
a mirror and appreciate this never
forget you are beautiful compared to a
fish because life is all about
perspective this book loves you it can
sustain you with frustration and have
you ever closer to success and failure
it is wisdom and ignorance it is hope
and despair it is enlightenment
it is not lasagna you can't eat it don't
try and eat it but you read it and look
at the pictures for in it you will
discover the inner workings of the
incredible mind and teachings of Buddha
pie
you
Wow